we are going to be chatting about not
only job search strategies but actually
creating a plan and to do that
effectively while we can't necessarily
get out of the house and we have to kind
of operate from the safety of our homes
so that's what we're gonna be focusing
on today so yeah let's go ahead and jump
right in so just a brief introduction of
myself so my name is Brett Ellis I am a
career coach here with Udacity I've been
here since April of 2019 so a little
over a year
most of my background is working with
college students graduate students and
in really in the higher education space
but I really enjoyed the career
development aspect of working with
students in helping them transition into
full-time roles I also like to make it
clear that you know certain career
coaches have certain areas of expertise
so if you're ever interested in chatting
with the career coach about specifically
about things like personal branding
LinkedIn and networking that's kind of
an area that I specialize in and so if
you have opportunities to do that feel
free to reach out and this is really
kind of my favorite part of this role is
being able to engage with different
groups and have you all participate in a
common learning experience and you know
feel free to ask any questions that you
have throughout my goal is to make this
as interactive as possible so if you
ever have a question or ever have a
comment or just want to chime in feel
free to unmute your mic as well you
don't have to just primarily use the
chat but if that's what you're
comfortable with
we can do that as well so
today we're going to be talking about
the importance of referrals and why they
are so important and why it's impactful
from from a business perspective and why
you should include that as part of your
job search then we're gonna jump into an
actual strategy or a plan that you can
start utilizing as early as today to
start making more progress towards your
goals and I'll talk about why that's
important when we talk about the the
planning section of it then we'll talk
about networking and relationship
building because that is going to be a
key way for you to start landing some of
those referrals and you've probably
heard that you should be doing this but
I'll give you some intentional things
that you can actually start implementing
soon and then we'll talk about personal
branding where I feel is often kind of
left out of the conversation as it
relates to job searching but can be one
of the most effective strategies for you
to implement as it relates to you
transitioning into your ideal next step
and then hopefully we'll have some time
for Q&A towards the end it looks like we
have about 17 people in here so it is a
fairly small group as I mentioned feel
free to jump off your mic or unmute your
video whatever as we can kind of keep
this a little bit more engaged that way
but once again the chat function is
perfectly fine to use as well so I want
to hear from you find your way to the
chat again if you haven't I want to hear
from as many people as possible
do you have an intentional job search
strategy or do you have a plan a job
search plan at all is it written down I
want you to to answer in the chat and
then give me some context if you do have
a plan I want to see where everybody's
at so I can navigate this conversation a
little bit more intentionally myself so
find the chat or unmute your mic and let
me know what your plan is or if you have
a plan so Susan says she does not have a
plan that is okay that's what we're here
to do today so if you don't have a plan
that is fine that's what we're going to
help you figure out today Daniela says
no not really so hopefully we can get
you on the right track as well anybody
else
Tony says find job postings that I feel
fit my skills submit applications with
cover letters and hope for the best
so Tony I might pick on you
a little bit today but it's only out of
love I think that that's what most job
seekers tend to do and I want to kind of
show you a more effective strategy that
you might not necessarily have thought
of so thank you for sharing that let's
see just LinkedIn Alerts job portals
LinkedIn notes and resumes okay so you
might have started to see how how
effective that process is as well so for
some of you who have been doing these
things may not have necessarily been
working too well so I really want to
kind of dive in and make sure that you
all are focusing your time and your
energy on things that are gonna provide
you with more return on your investment
while you are job searching because it
can be a very lengthy process sometimes
it can be a very challenging emotional
journey for you as well and so having a
plan and having a sense of control will
help you to feel like you are actually
making progress towards the goals that
you have so that is also my goal today
and what I hope you all will kind of
take away from this session so thank you
all for jumping in and sharing it's not
always the easiest thing to do to say we
need help but I appreciate everybody who
did share in the comments stay engaged
so we can have a more back-and-forth
kind of conversation so yeah as I kind
of mentioned very briefly this is
strategy that I see most job seekers
take so I call it the reactive approach
and that's because you're seeing an
opening or you're aware of an opening
and then you're reacting to it and the
reason why this can be a little bit
challenging is because sometimes you're
already behind when you see that posting
you may see that posting was listed five
days ago some companies are moving so
quickly that they may already start
reviewing resumes by the sixth or
seventh day some may be drawn out a
little bit further but you want to try
to get in on the proactive side so that
you're aware immediately when positions
become available and you can navigate
other processes of finding jobs other
than just applying for them online so
that is my goal today as I mentioned
before but this is kind of the the
reactive approach that I see most job
seekers take and to be completely honest
with you a not very successful approach
is this kind of aware
of job openings and then applying online
one of the reasons why it's not
effective is because that's what most
people are doing and any way that you
can stand out and the job search process
is going to be good for you so that is
what we're gonna focus on today we have
a question before we jump in hi is it a
good idea to start applying for jobs
finished first project and working on
second project so I think it depends
more on the experience that you're
bringing previously I don't think that
having one or two projects under your
belt is going to be enough to qualify
you for any job so I I think that's
probably more a one on one question that
you want to kind of process through with
a career coach just because that is a
little bit more in-depth and just a
simple quick answer well yeah any
questions feel free to keep them coming
I'm monitoring those as I'm part as I'm
presenting the the webinar as well so
let's talk about why this process is not
very effective so depending on the
research that you'll see depending on
the source you'll find that this kind of
numbers between 70 to 85 percent of jobs
are not posted online so that bullet
alone should kind of shock some people
out of going this route at least as
their plan a my goal with this session
is not to discourage you from applying
for jobs online at all but I do want you
to move it down on your list of
priorities and kind of focus on some
things that are gonna be a little bit
more impactful another thing to consider
is that most major companies use what
are called applicant tracking systems so
some of you might be familiar with what
those are I think there people are
starting to learn a little bit more
about what they're about but if not the
next slide I'm going to go through that
a little bit more in detail so if you
don't know what that means that's okay
just stay tuned for the next slide and
then another thing to consider is is
thinking about this from a business
perspective I think a lot of job seekers
don't take the time to put themselves in
the position of somebody who's hiring
and so they don't often fully think
through like what would be the most
effective or what would I want to see
from someone who was interested in
working for me
so one of the things that we'll talk
about is is how employers prefer to hire
these professionals with
of inexperience so you know sometimes
just completing a nano degree or just
completing a college degree or just
completing a course is not necessarily
going to be enough to land jobs you have
to pair that with really good experience
and applying the things that you owe
your learning so they're looking for
that but they're also doing some
candidate sourcing of their own through
platforms like LinkedIn where they're
not necessarily reviewing all the
applications that are coming in but they
are actively seeking the type of
candidate that they want so they have an
idea in mind of who they want to work
for them and they use LinkedIn as a way
to find it will we'll talk about a
similar strategy for how you can kind of
do the reverse and then that through
referrals referrals are extremely
important because referrals are
basically someone at the company saying
I think this person would be a good fit
for this role so you have somebody on
the inside who's potentially already a
good employee saying they have another
person who could be a really good
employee at this company and from a
business perspective from a hiring
perspective it makes a lot of sense to
prioritize that because you know you
have kind of that word-of-mouth and
someone you trust versus having to go
through an entire interview process or
reviewing a ton of resumes and filtering
through people when you already have
kind of an ideal candidate or maybe
several candidates in front of you
already let's see yeah yeah here and if
you can correct me if I'm saying it
incorrectly the main problem in landing
a job is experience they suggest you
know a ton of info even as a junior yeah
that's a great point
and I think that that's relevant for a
lot of different industries and so I
think as early as you can start gaining
some experience and applying what you're
learning the better but if you want to
talk about that a little bit further I
can forward you to another webinar that
I facilitated with Udacity a couple of
months ago it's around gaining
experience so if we have time towards
the Q&A remind me and I'll drop the link
for that in the chat yeah these are just
a couple of reasons why applying online
is just not the most effective strategy
that you can implement and once again
this is not to say to avoid doing it
completely but maybe include that as
just part of your strategy and not the
entire part
so um as I mentioned before I did want
to do this kind of brief overview of
applicant tracking systems for those of
you who might not be familiar I mean
some of you may have been applying for
jobs and wondering why you're not
hearing back and this could be the
culprit here so applicant tracking
systems are basically software platforms
that are designed to filter out
applications through the use of keywords
so they're not filtering in which means
they're trying their best to remove
anybody who might not be qualified for
their role and the reason why this is
important is because you know several
years ago you had to potentially go to
the library type up a resume print it
off mail it off get a stamp and do all
these things now with the ease of
applying online really there's no
barrier to entry for anybody applying
for any job from anywhere at any time
and so companies have had a really
difficult time keeping up with the
amount of applications that they're
getting and so they've had to implement
these systems to filter out as much as
they can people who they deem not
qualified in the challenging part about
that is they're kind of making that
they're setting that criteria based on
keywords and so those keywords are going
to be coming directly from job
descriptions so if you see a position as
a front-end developer that you want to
apply for and your resume doesn't do a
good job of matching that in terms of
the keywords that they've deemed most
important then you might be getting
filtered out by a software platform
before a human ever actually sees your
resume you know with their own eyes so
it's important for you to keep in mind
that a lot of major companies use these
systems and this is another just kind of
adding another layer to why applying for
jobs online is a lot more challenging
and so if you are going to go the route
of applying for jobs online you need to
be aware of these applicant tracking
systems so that you are reminded to
always always always tailor your resume
for the position that you're applying
for I know that you know some people
might have heard that but have not
necessarily thought that it was
necessary it is if you want to compete
for some of the bigger companies and the
companies that use applicant tracking
system
because even if you created a resume
that is tailored to keywords for one
company those keywords might look
completely different for the other ones
so it's important that you always tailor
your resumes when applying and once
again you can start to see how this
might take up a lot of time that is
there's very very little you know return
on investment for that time that you're
spending so we're talking potentially 30
minutes to an hour tailoring a resume to
fit keywords but then also potentially
writing a cover letter on top of it I
personally feel like that time could be
spent more effectively elsewhere sorry
let me go back but yeah just to keep all
of these things in mind but if you are
going to be applying for jobs online you
should be tailoring those resumes every
single time and aware of these applicant
tracking systems here are a couple of
resources just on the the right side
that can help you navigate these ATS
systems so skill sinker comm is a great
resource where you can actually copy and
paste your resume next to the job
description and it will give you
somewhat of a score that lets you know
how well you might perform an ATS
they're not going to be a hundred
percent accurate though because a lot of
companies use different ATS systems
there are different providers for that
and job scan basically does the same
thing but one thing to note is that
through skill sink or military and
students get a year free I don't know if
that applies to more traditional
university degrees or if nanodegrees
would apply but you can always reach out
to their support team and ask that tony
says that is why i only apply to like
three to five jobs a week due to the
time they take yes and that is that is
good to a certain extent because you
want to focus on quality I hear a lot of
people say I applied for 50 jobs this
week and I have to think to myself do
you really see yourself engaged or you
know doing well at all 50 companies that
you applied for it seems a little bit
out there and I think that when you
start getting into that process of
applying to jobs and applying and
applying and applying it's almost like
running on a hamster wheel and you're
just kind of running in place and not
really getting anywhere and so I want a
to start thinking of having a plan that
is a little bit more beginning and end
and we can take tangible steps to get to
that point so yeah if there are any
questions about ATS systems please drop
them in the chat I'll make sure to get
to those but I want to make sure this is
clear this is a really really important
to understand for anybody who's going
through a job search
okay so now let's talk about a strategy
and you can kind of formulate this into
a plan as well so if it helps feel free
to take a screenshot or take a picture
with your phone this is probably
something that you'll refer back to
we're obviously not going to have enough
time for everybody to create a full job
search plan right now but you can come
back to these on your own time and
really take some time to brainstorm and
reflect and think through and you know
even prepare questions that you can
potentially share when you have a
one-on-one with a coach or just in your
your student hub or group chat you know
ask these questions keep be very
intentional through this process so
we'll start at the top so this is what I
would say is like the first step and
usually any career coaching call that
I'm having with a Udacity student this
is really the the first call that most
of my students get is this kind of
diagram here so the first thing I think
is really important for you to do is to
find your focus and what I mean by that
is you know it's great for you to have
multiple interests it's great for you to
have a wide range of skill sets but when
you're going through a job search you
want to have a very clear brand and so
you want to try to focus as much as you
can the types of positions that you're
looking for so you don't want to be that
person who has one resume that is for
software engineering data analysts
machine learning like you know multiple
different types of roles you want to
have that focus as clear as possible now
it is okay for you to have you know
upwards of two or three focuses but it
becomes more challenging
the more different that they are so for
example you probably wouldn't want to
put four with a brand that you are a
software developer a graphic designer
and an accountant those are three very
different areas but if you find things
that are a little bit closer that's
gonna make it easier for you but it's
important that you take time to find
your focus so if you don't know what
types of positions that you're gonna be
targeting once you complete your nano
degree or are currently working towards
now really spend some time to figure
that out because that's where you should
be starting if you're just wandering
aimlessly and applying to whatever sees
fit
you're not gonna have as much success
that way so try to start with a focus
then once you have that focus in terms
of the types of positions that you're
going to want to look for now you want
to create a list of companies so these
should if you're if you're listening in
and wondering how do I apply this as
soon as this ends step one is to have
your focus or refine your focus step two
is to create a list of companies so you
could use something like you know you
could write it down on paper if you want
I would recommend doing it in like Excel
or a Google sheets somewhere to where
you can organize that list of companies
and you can even have a column for names
of people that you've contacted so it'll
help you give you a little bit more
organization to your search process in
general so you have that list of
companies then we can start targeting
people who work at those companies and
that is the next step so I would say as
you're putting them together that list
of companies maybe start with like 10 I
think that's a good number to kind of
have one of the things to keep in mind
and I want to use this moment to be very
realistic with you all not all of you
are going to find jobs at Amazon Google
Netflix and Facebook I you know I
probably speak to you know about 75% of
the Udacity students I talked to say
that they want to work at one of those
five companies and wow that is a great
goal and some of them will actually
achieve it
I don't want people's focuses to be at
the top companies in the world and only
those companies because even if you're
qualified you're competing with the best
people in the entire world and so while
I'm in full support I think you should
go for it I think you should do it
do not be closed-minded to smaller
companies startups medium-size companies
I recommend that as you're creating a
list make that list diverse include big
companies include medium-sized companies
include startups as much as you can to
diversify your options and give yourself
a better chance especially if you're at
a place where you're saying I really
just want a job that's gonna allow me to
apply the things I've learned you can
you you'll want to be a little bit more
open versus the people out there who are
saying I love my job right now I'm
taking this nanodegree to level up my
skills you could be a little bit more
picky with the types of roles that
you're looking for and maybe say okay
I'm gonna wait until I get one of those
but it depends on what your priorities
are but you should also keep in mind the
level of competition it's not just about
you being qualified it's also about you
beating out some of the best people in
the world so just keep that in mind not
to discourage you once again but just be
realistic through this process as well
because we also have you know things
going on in the world that are limiting
the amount of opportunities as well so
give yourself the best chance and be
realistic with your skill set if you're
brand new to what you're learning you
may not be the best candidate for a more
competitive company whereas if you're
brand new and looking for a place to
start a smaller business or a startup
might be an ideal starting ground for
you so keep those things in mind as
you're creating your list and if you
have any questions about this process
feel free to drop those in the chat as I
mentioned before but once you take some
time to do step 1 find your focus or
refine your focus create that list of
companies and now you want to start
finding strategic connections so there
are a couple of ways that you can do
this one being LinkedIn which I'll go
into a little bit more detail and a
little bit too is just networking in
general so getting trying to get
involved with professional organizations
is a great opportunity
joining meet up groups I love meetup
groups and I think that a lot of Udacity
students have gained a lot of value from
meetup groups so let me know if in the
zoom chat if you've ever been a part of
one or currently part of one but I think
meetup is great if you type in meetup
comm or you can download the app on your
phone
those are that that's a really good good
place for you to actually join a
targeted group so meetup is not just
professional it's not just for
networking you can also join meetups so
I might join a a meetup group for
Nintendo switch players or I might join
a meetup group for concert goers in
Atlanta but they also have meetup groups
that are very specific to your
profession and so they may have meetup
groups for data scientists they may have
general groups for just technology
professionals they may have you know
smaller groups that are a little bit
more broad so it may be like women in
marketing or something like that and so
the more specific you can get the better
but if you can't find those or you're in
a less kind of populated area go with a
broader option like you know tech
professionals or something like that one
thing to note is that meetup is
obviously more so for you to meet up in
person but we can't really do that too
much right now one good thing though is
that a lot of meetup groups are
transitioning their events and their
programming to be online and to be
virtual and so they're having panels
they're having conferences they're
having workshops meet-and-greet speed
networking events so don't don't forget
about that that resource because they've
adapted as well and another thing to
think about is if you are trying to
transition to a different location this
is a better opportunity for you to
connect with people because they're not
necessarily meeting in person you don't
have to be physically located there so
if you are in you know let's say you're
in the US if you live in Chicago but you
want to move to New York join a meetup
group there and engage with them in
these online events now or if you are
looking to even transition from a
different country you could potentially
start getting involved with some of
these groups right now Clayton says
meetup is an amazing tool more often
than not a lot of folks I know have
found positions through that sort of
networking I have as well
I even hosted a networking jobs fair
precoded and had 1,000 people there
there's a huge benefit to meetups oh
yeah Clayton has had some success with
meetups as well I have even if they're
not professional I highly encourage you
all just get used to networking because
I think where people get nervous as it
relates to networking is they focus too
much on I am here to get a job and
people on the receiving end kind of know
that or they can see that from how
you're interacting with people but you
should really be approaching these as
just a way to start and build
relationships with people that you think
could potentially be good connections so
it's not just about connecting with
people so that they can get you a job
when you go about it that way you're not
going to enjoy networking I can kind of
promise you now especially if you're
someone who feels a little bit more
introverted these online meetups can be
a really good place to start but also if
you ever if we get back to meeting in
person soon keep those things in mind
when you're at events your goal there
should be to genuinely connect with
people who you are kind of on the same
level with and trying to find things
outside of just a job at that company
that you want to connect with them over
so there's a question don't you think
it's time-consuming how is it taking
care of everything going on in life so I
will say this it is time-consuming but I
will also say that if you want to find a
good job you're better off going this
route then applying for jobs online so
this strategy obviously you can start to
see that this process takes a lot longer
than applying for jobs online but
there's there's no timeline that says
applying for jobs online gets you a role
quicker because through this process
referrals are by far the number one way
you're going to get interviews and get
hired and so you could be applying for
jobs online very quickly for an entire
year without finding a new role or you
could go through this process that that
could take you a couple of months and
find something within two to three
months but I've seen it happen much
quicker for people but I've also seen it
take longer so it's just it's also
important for you to keep in mind that
this is not a guarantee there are no
guaranteed strategies out there this is
just what I found to be the most
effective and even in a long term I've
seen this to be more effective so it is
time consuming yes but sometimes that's
how you stand out from everybody else
but great question
so yeah meetup is a great resource also
LinkedIn is extremely valuable here
because you can go in and you can
actually search that company that is on
your list search that company and when
you're looking for people to connect
with I would encourage you to a lot of
people just go towards recruiters or
they look for HR directors or HR
managers but you also want to kind of
focus on people who are in the roles
that you want to be in because you're
not gonna have a full-out conversation
with a recruiter about the future of a I
like you would
with the machine learning engineer at
the company that you want to work for so
I would encourage you to look into
trying to find those people so you can
just search on LinkedIn in that search
bar let's see ABC company machine
learning engineer that's the type of
position that you're targeting search
for that on LinkedIn and then you will
get a list of different resources I'm
sorry a list of different people who fit
that description and so look at their
profiles go to their profiles read their
profiles see what it says in the air
about section is there anything there
that you can connect with outside of
just that company in that job look at
their experience maybe you all have done
similar work in the past and they made a
transition so they may have a similar
career path maybe they worked at the
same company that you used to work for
or currently work for maybe they went to
the same university or also completed a
nano degree program these are all things
that you can use as a way to break the
ice and introduce that conversation so
keep that in mind your goal is not to go
and find somebody that works for a
company that you're interested in
working for and asking them hey can you
submit a referral this is about taking
time to build relationships and invest
in networking so that when positions
become available you have a lot better
chance to to get them as soon as they're
available so yeah I'll go into that a
little bit more in detail on a future
slide but I see
Ishmael says Eventbrite app is a great
way to find meetups as well yes that's
when I forgot to mention Eventbrite is
great Eventbrite is great for more kind
of like pop-up events as well so it may
not be a dedicated meetup group but you
may see that one person is having an
event that you're interested in so you
can go on there and not only is it good
for hosting events but you can actually
search and browse by category as well so
yeah look into that there may be some
other ones that we're not thinking of
that might be a little bit more
regionally specific so if you know of
any feel free to drop those in the chat
where you're located and if that has
worked well for you Clayton says I'd
also echo what Brett is saying here when
job searching I search for depth not
breadth of opportunities absolutely
finding at least one event networking
opportunity a week will go a lot further
than plugging in
online very very true and and I would
even go to say you know you could at
least do one a month if you're active in
a job search you should be doing
something closer to a week but one of
the things that I encourage people to
think about you know once you find that
new role or if you're in your role and
you're currently happy do not see a job
search is something that you start and
stop every time you're looking for a
role these are things that you should be
doing throughout your entire career so
that each time you make a career
transition it's much smoother so if
you're in a job that you absolutely love
you should still be networking if you
are if you just started a job you should
still be connecting with people at
companies that you want to work for
someday this is not a start and stop
thing that you do in the more that you
do it consistently the easier the
process gets to where you know if you're
moving on to kind of a further step
doing some personal branding you're
sometimes avoiding the needs job search
at all because people are reaching out
to you let's see what do I ask talk to
employee let's say in Netflix that fit
my Brack background sorry for having a
neat naive question yeah so I think you
know they're I won't give a template I
would never give like a guidelines I
think you have to realize you're talking
to people and so you have to be able to
connect with them first and foremost so
there's nothing I would say you should
say this I think it's just important for
you to read their profile and genuinely
try to connect with them if you're going
through that list of people and you say
you know what I could see myself having
a friendship or a professional
relationship with this person even if it
didn't lead to a job those are the
people that you want to be reaching out
to because it's gonna make that
connection much stronger and kind of
fast-track that referral process in a
lot of cases so yeah that's where that
networking and building relationships
comes in so you know outside of just
connecting with them for the first time
that's not always enough you know
sometimes if you are able to find those
people that you have a lot in common
with it can be as quick as one meeting
or one phone call or one video chat has
happened several times for me where you
know I've met somebody at a company that
I'm interested in and they say you know
if you ever need a referral please let
me know but then on the other hand there
have also been such
Asians were I was like you know we
didn't really talk about much maybe I
shouldn't ask for that right off the bat
I need to spend more time investing in
this relationship let me mark that down
in my document and plan to follow up
with them in a month and then you know
you build that relationship and you find
opportunities to help each other and
that's what gets people to want to help
you as well so yeah and then personal
branding personal branding is kind of
the next step so if the first part of
this seems like you kind of need to
start from scratch and it's gonna take a
lot a while for you to do this
that's okay personal branding I would
say is kind of the next step so once you
get comfortable through this process you
know and this doesn't mean that you have
to complete the first three in order to
get there you can be doing all of these
things at once but personal branding is
really impactful because basically what
you're doing is you are showcasing that
you are an expert and you're publicizing
that in a sense to where if you were to
use a platform like LinkedIn let's say
so you go on LinkedIn and you type a
post you know once a week
sharing the future of digital marketing
that is going to show to people that
you're an expert in digital marketing so
when they have an opening or they hear
of an opening at their company they may
think hmm I should reach out to that one
person who's always posting about it
because they're an expert and so you
want to kind of be seen as that through
creating your own content whether that's
just quick posts on LinkedIn it could be
writing articles on LinkedIn it could be
writing articles on a platform like
medium it could be you sharing what
projects you're working on and include
links to github so people can connect
with you there but really it's just
about getting the word out about the
work I'm sorry that you're doing so you
know through public speaking getting
featured in articles writing articles
you know showing up to events frequently
so people know who you are posting
quickly on social media can go really
far and this is what kind of leads you
into that area of where you are putting
out feelers for people to reach out to
you it's kind of like marketing but
you're treating yourself as the business
and your customers are
potential employers so it probably is
one of the most impactful but also one
of the more difficult strategies so if
this seems a little bit outside of your
comfort zone right now that's perfectly
fine but get comfortable with some of
these other areas so that when you think
about adding personal branding to your
search strategy you can be more
effective with it obviously you know you
might have questions or concerns about
this working if you need to follow up
this is a great topic to kind of follow
up on usually after I go through my
first coaching call with Udacity
students kind of covering this topic we
will plan our follow-up session to talk
about their LinkedIn profiles so I'm
also gonna try to make a note to include
the link to that webinar as well because
LinkedIn is really impactful in all of
these areas and you want to make sure
that you have a really solid profile to
get started so I'll try to share that
link as well maybe the next time I ask
for you some feedback and then lastly is
kind of that awareness so we see how
that's different from the first the
first slide about reactive job searching
where you're aware of it and then you
apply this is kind of doing everything
before that that opportunity has even
become available so you very well could
be spending all of this time for a job
opening that is not going to exist but
it is likely that you know for the
companies that you're targeting if
you're targeting companies that would
you know likely hire someone with your
skill set you'd be surprised how quickly
this can happen and so when you do see
oh so-and-so is hiring they're on my
list let me reach out to my connection
and then you can say hey I saw that you
have an opening would you mind
submitting a referral for my application
or sending the application materials to
your hiring manager at that point you're
not sending that to a stranger this is
someone you've taken a little bit of
time to get to know you've established
that it's okay for you to reach out to
them for help that you've also showcased
ways that you plan to make the
relationship mutually beneficial and so
it becomes less of an ask there one of
the things that I would also include is
when you're creating that list of
companies go to their application
website their HR website a lot of them
allow you to sign up for email alerts
when positions become available so as
soon as there
open you can go ahead and reach out to
that person really jump on it the other
thing is you know as I mentioned before
sometimes they Merritt reach out to you
there was this was probably two years
ago I was looking to make a transition
from higher ed into campus recruiting
and I found somebody who worked it you
know one of the top companies on my list
and I said oh yeah he made this same
transition let me meet with him and so
he and I had a really good conversation
about how he made that transition and I
just shared how much I was kind of
interested in doing that work and then I
want to say like a month and a half
later he said hey one of our team
members is leaving send me your resume
so I can share it with my supervisor so
this was before a position was even made
available online and I was interviewing
for a position that hadn't even been
posted so it almost some it can
sometimes guarantee a first-round
interview at least a chance for you to
share what you can do for them so it
does work I've seen it work extremely
well and the other thing too is like
this is this may take a little bit
longer but this is the idea of this is
to get you into the companies that you
want to work for doing what you want to
do versus just finding a job that you
found online kind of haphazardly so it
provides a little bit more intention and
so this may be your long-term strategy
while you continue working on a
short-term strategy as well but then
again we only have you know a certain
amount of hours in the day to do this so
I would recommend this route if you want
to experience a little bit more success
but it can sometimes take a little bit
longer but it can also take longer if
you're just applying online so there's
you know at the end of the day you have
humans making decisions and we can never
control that so let's see so you're
advising to contact and build a
relationship with other engineers in the
targeted company why don't we contact
the recruiters directly so that's a good
question and it's not just for engineers
anybody who's kind of looking to build
relationships online you are doing this
instead of recruiters because guess what
everybody else is doing they're reaching
out directly to the recruiters and so
sometimes it's just a matter of finding
people whose inboxes aren't flooded with
matches messages every single day it's
also about connecting with people who
have actually done the transition that
you're
trying to do a recruiter hasn't gotten a
job as an engineer at that company that
person has so they can talk to you about
what they had to showcase in their
interview what they put on their resume
what they're currently looking for on
their team and then sometimes those
people who are actually on the team are
the ones who are interviewing you beyond
the recruiter making the connection so
you know oftentimes some recruiters will
kind of find the person and then pass
them off to the team who's actually
going to be working with them so
reaching out to the people in those
roles is more impactful for a lot of
different reasons
you can still contact recruiters by by
all means but I would not limit it to
that I think you'll have more success
with reaching out to people who are in
those roles but still reach out to
recruiters because there Martin there
might be some who are a little bit more
responsive a little bit more friendly
and more willing to help but that's not
always the case from what I've seen in
the hiring industry so yeah just be
aware not every single thing that I say
is gonna relate directly to every single
person but just take what you believe
take what you don't and kind of leave
what everything else but yeah just take
these things into account and keep in
mind as you're putting together an
actual strategy so this can actually
serve as your plan your you've got your
focus your target companies your keeping
track of the people that you're reaching
out to your attending networking events
within your industry
one thing about that list is that list
does not necessarily need to be static
so it can change you could have a
conversation with somebody and realize
you don't want to work there and you can
take that off your list you may have a
conversation with someone you meet in a
virtual meetup group and they say I work
for XYZ company and I absolutely love it
here you might then add that to your
list of companies and now you already
have a connection there that you can
continue furthering that relationship so
there's a lot of benefits to doing this
outside of just job searching if you are
freelancing or if you are looking to
start your own business someday this is
still relevant you know I don't think
people realize that like you know
relationships are what rule the world
and so you know whether that's job
searching building a business dating
everything is really focused on you
being able
to connect with people so that they
trust you and will support you in your
own goals so yeah let's keep moving
great questions so far now I want to get
into some specifics that you might
already have some questions about so
Before we jump into that feel free to
hop back in the chat I know I talked at
you for a while and I want to make sure
that you guys get a chance to talk at me
a little bit umm so feel free to drop in
what companies you're targeting I'm
interested in knowing and hearing from
you all don't be discouraged by anything
that I shared I just want to know what
ones you're currently targeting Juan
says how would this strategy change when
you were looking for a career change
that is when you have work experience
for you're looking for a new job so I
would say that this strategy doesn't
change too much I think you if you are
making a transition or a career change
you really really should use that
strategy because if you're making a
career change and you're applying online
the only thing that speaks for you is
your resume which is not going to be as
competitive as those people who have
several years of experience doing that
same job and so through those
relationships you have people who are
willing to kind of put their reputation
on the line to say hey I know one I know
he's been really learning this new skill
I know he can do this job he's not you
know necessarily our ideal candidate but
I think we should give them an interview
those are things that are gonna happen
people are not gonna take a look at your
resume and say oh you were doing this
for ten years and now you're doing this
we should give you a chance I don't
think you're gonna see that as
frequently I think you have to always
approach it from a business perspective
and think would I hire this person who
I'm taking a chance on and it's not even
about hiring sometimes it's sometimes
it's about am i picking the best
candidates to actually interview and you
have people with traditional backgrounds
that make more sense versus something
that's a little bit different you might
wonder well why in the heck is this
person applying for this job so that's
where that networking comes in and is a
lot more beneficial when you go into it
with with intention because anytime you
make a career change it's going to be
challenging the employers are not going
to see an online course or a university
degree or a nano degree and say that's
the reason why we should hire this
person I think you
have to find unique ways to you know use
your nanodegree because that's building
your skills find ways to apply those
skills in that experience to real-world
problems that you know other businesses
need help with that you can volunteer to
do and whatnot and then you need to
build your network that's for everybody
but I think all three of those things
are emphasized for people who are making
a career change yeah that's a great
question but yeah what what company what
companies are you all targeting let me
know in the chat box um
I'm focusing on the fashion industry but
really not closing any doors okay
that's interesting so one of the things
I would encourage you to do is check in
on the fashion industry I'm sure they're
doing pretty well in terms of like
online sales but that might help you
give you a better idea of which types of
companies the target obviously the ones
that are focused on the more
brick-and-mortar are probably struggling
a little bit right now with social
distancing so some of those companies
that might be more pushing their online
brands can be really really cool to
target indeed so indeed is more like a
job board a job searching website but
you might also be searching for a job
there I don't know tech companies okay
let's see Daimler Mercedes I'm assuming
that's probably a self-driving car
person um my background experiences in
healthcare so my job searches in that
scope so that's a good point to bring up
so if you are looking to make a
transition you're going to want to find
ways to make that I say to kind of
decorate that bridge right so if you're
making a transition from one thing to a
next try to find ways to make that
easier so maybe that's you staying in
the same industry or maybe that's you
working towards an industry that your
background is in or your previous
education is in so that you have more
credibility of just working in that
industry even if it's not so much
working in that specific position
Suzanne is looking for a venture
capitalist with startup companies okay
great
tony has a couple Splunk dropbox ever
lost smaller companies in Chicago as I'm
thinking of moving
so yeah meetup could be a really great
opportunity for you as well as reaching
out to
people on linkedin medical imaging
technical so yeah anything in the
healthcare industry that involves IT is
obviously going to be booming and was
booming pre kovat and will continue to
boom post cove it so that's great
banking finance is also not taking too
many hits at least in terms of like
their industry in general the ones that
are focused primarily online they're
doing fine because things haven't
changed too much from them yeah and then
aerospace hopefully it'll survive
through kovat yes I'm looking for
auditing consulting companies okay great
so that is helpful for me thank you all
for taking some time to share that so
yeah we talked a little about this so
this will be a little bit of review so
as far as the networking and
relationship building goes here a couple
of in-person options traditionally
in-person options obviously a lot of
them have transitioned online so they're
still great resources one of the things
I hadn't mentioned previously is this
the one-on-one coffee or lunch chats so
when things do get back to normal or as
close as normal as we're going to get
one of the things I encourage you to do
is if you have the budget or are willing
to spend the money offer to buy people
lunch to have a conversation with them
especially if you feel like you don't
have a whole lot to offer in the initial
stages of your relationship so for
example some of the previous experiences
I mentioned you know I offered to buy
someone lunch and at the end of that
conversation they said if I needed a
referral I could reach out to them the
good thing about that is they ended up
saying no I'm okay with just meeting
around like 2:00 p.m. and so you know
off from just offering a loan can
sometimes you know showcase to them that
you're serious and that you value their
time that's really what it's about
but I think if you are interested in
meeting someone at a company and
learning from their experience you do
want to think about how can you provide
value to their situation as well you
don't want it to be one-sided because
then that person is gonna be less likely
to want to continue to engage with you
so a very effective strategy that I've
used not only for you know my own career
but also for my business you know I
think having a face-to-face conversation
over food is just always a bonding
experience so consider that when things
get a little bit closer to normal and
then online I mentioned these LinkedIn
and online communities but your goal is
to what I think like quoted take your
conversations off line which would
ideally be in-person or face-to-face
one-on-one but I would transition that
to also include one-on-one phone calls
virtual chat so if you meet at an event
bright event or you meet at a meetup
group try to actually have a phone call
or a video chat with the people that
you're meeting one-on-one you want to
kind of further that relationship and
that one-on-one is going to be best
especially if you can do video because
it's the closest to face-to-face that
we're gonna get for a while so try to
always take that I should say take that
conversation one-on-one but also take it
offline if you can and when things get
back to normal that's going to help you
further build those relationships
so here a couple of tips and I shared a
couple of these before but just to kind
of give you a breakdown you can also
kind of screenshot this or take a quick
pic to keep all of these in mind before
you start reaching out to people so you
can use the search feature as I
mentioned before to find someone at the
company on your list then you want to
review those results and you want to to
kind of go through their profile and see
if you have things in common or if you
can find things in common another thing
that I hadn't mentioned previously is
you know when you look at somebody's
profile you can also check between
usually their top section where it has
their about their summary and their
experience for the people who are a
little bit more active on LinkedIn they
will have a bar there that says activity
and that's helpful to look at because if
they like to post a day ago and
commented on a post two days ago one
they're more likely to see your message
because they're fairly active on
LinkedIn but to considering the fact
that they're engaging with their
community they probably bought into the
idea of LinkedIn a little bit more and
maybe more willing to have a
conversation and network because that's
really what the platform's built to do
versus you know somebody who you don't
see that activity bar meaning they're
probably not very active or you go click
on their activity and they comment on a
post three months ago that might not be
the best person to reach out to because
chances are they're not logging in as
frequently so they might not even see
your message or they're just not bought
into this idea of connecting and they
just kind of have their Linkedin to you
know post whenever they get a new job or
update their resume which is what we
want to get away from but yeah so that's
a good thing to take a look at and then
also just try to find something that you
have in common or as I mentioned take an
interest in their work so if you see
that they've written a post or written
an article or have an event coming up
you know invest in that you know go read
or go tune into their webinar their live
or whatever and you know follow up with
a message and say hey I attended the
webinar that you did through the women
in tech meetup I'd love to have a
conversation about your what you said
about you know blank and then you start
having a conversation with that person
they they've
seen that you've taken an interest in
them beyond just kind of a job at their
company let's see a question how does it
work between genders female male just
thinking in my mind I'm talking about
networking yeah that's a good question
so I I will say that I'm primarily
speaking from a u.s. lens I haven't had
the experience of you know doing a whole
lot of networking internationally other
than with students but I do get this
question here and there so I think it is
sometimes a cultural thing we're trying
to meet up with someone one-on-one might
be seen as a little bit more flirtatious
or towards the dating in I think it's
important for you to make clear what
your goals are in that case from that
conversation also you know potentially
offer to meet in a very public place so
that people don't feel nervous or afraid
I think that those are good options to
think about but also be aware of
cultural differences and how that might
play into effect but if if you're
uncomfortable with that I would say just
start that conversation online and make
it clear to them that you're not
interested in in in in you know a dating
relationship or something personal you
want it to be a little bit more so
professional I think that's okay okay so
you're located in the US so yeah I don't
think that it's too out of the norm for
people to ask to meet up on LinkedIn I
think that that's fairly common but you
can't if they're nervous just make it
clear then what your goals are um
and then yeah you want to make that
connection and break the ice to start
that conversation so you're not just
starting that conversation with hey
stranger I want to have a video chat
with you you know you're you're taking
some time to kind of break the ice ask
them questions I recently reached out to
a lot of different people in my industry
as a way to build my network during the
downtime and I ask them a question at
the end I said how do you think that
what are the biggest challenges that
you're seeing with career services from
a distance or working remotely just a
way to break the ice and and start the
conversation and then these are just a
couple things to get keep in mind I like
to remind people that you will get
ignored it is going to happen and so go
into this knowing that and don't get too
disappointed when you don't hear back
from people because it is just
to happen we get busy we don't want to
feel like we're bombarded from people
who aren't necessarily adding value to
our situation sometimes and so we all
get caught up in this so just keep in
mind that you will get ignored it's okay
but then also to be persistent and
follow up so if you reach out to
somebody and they didn't reply or they
replied in the conversation and it you
know reach back out to them a week later
and and follow-up and if they don't
respond from there then it might be time
to take a hint that they're not that
interested so yeah just to kind of get a
recap of the the thing if you didn't get
a chance to kind of see it all in action
we're targeting companies we're finding
our focus finding connections building
those relationships further or building
them through networking doing some
personal branding that's kind of outside
of what we chatted about today I'll
include the link to those webinars so
you have access to that and then you
have that kind of awareness of the job
opening so then at that point you try to
reach back out and say hey friend can
you submit a referral for me that is
going to work much better than if you
try to kind of skip steps and jump
directly to that what if I sent my
resume to a company and I was ignored
should I still try to get a connection
there yeah I think that that's okay I
think you know for the most part the
people that you're trying to reach out
to may have not may not have even known
that you applied there or seen your
application it might have even got
filtered out so I would say it's still
worth it to try um let's skip this
because we don't have a ton of time so I
do want to end just a little bit early
so that we can get to Q&A and while you
all type in your questions I'm going to
take a second to get those links ready
for you all so since we skip that I just
want to give you that they're gonna be
full sessions like this one so you don't
have to watch them I know it can get
tiring listening to me for an entire
hour but all I'm gonna go grab those
links but yeah let me know in the chat
if you have any questions and we'll come
back well circle back when I get those
links to you all so yeah feel free to
type those in the chat right now if you
got what you were hoping to gain from
this session feel free to jump off the
call thank you so so
much for attending but if you have
questions or want those links go ahead
and type them in the chat and I'll grab
those right now feel free to jump on
your microphone as well if you want to
speak up
actually I'm going to share my screen so
that I can show you all where these are
located as well okay okay so really all
you have to do is go to youtube and type
in Udacity and then Udacity has a full
very like you know well-developed
YouTube presence there's almost 30,000
videos if you navigate to home sorry I
click the wrong thing if you navigate to
the playlists you'll find the playlists
that all of our career webinars are on
so I think it's even a little bit
further over here yeah so career
coaching events we have 53 different
videos there so if you go to that and
the reason why I wanted to show this is
because for those of you who are
watching the replay you won't be able to
see the links in the chat but you can
see we have a full list of webinars here
this is the last time we did this
session specifically but if you keep
looking there ones around remote jobs
there are ones about assessing cultural
fit and if you scroll down down down
this is one that I mentioned how can I
gain experience when nobody will hire me
that's one for you to explore different
options for you to gain experience if
you are making somewhat of a career
transition and then the other one is the
LinkedIn guide to interviews without
applying so that one is focused
primarily on your profile and making
sure that you have a really strong
profile to put forward and then the part
two is a little bit more advanced that's
getting into the personal branding
topics that we talked about and that's
going to showcase to you how best to
engage in other people's posts as well
as to create your own content so
hopefully that was helpful I'm actually
going to just show that and not drop the
links so that I can get to these
questions before we run out of time but
yeah if you need help just accessing
that just search Udacity on YouTube and
navigate that playlist
see how to appropriately evaluate your
skills so if you could just be a little
bit more specific in that question I'm
not sure exactly what you're asking feel
free to just clarify in the chat oh you
attended a webinar before yes thank you
for attending let's see how to
appropriately evaluate your skills so
yeah I think if you could just provide a
little bit more context that that would
be really helpful for me to understand
what you're really trying to ask or get
it but I think that is really important
to do is to review job descriptions so
even if you are kind of not currently
job searching but know what your ideal
next step is this is a great activity to
do start looking at those job
descriptions now and use that as a
roadmap to get to that point so if
they're you know different platforms
that you need to learn or different
experiences that you need to gain try to
do those in advance so that when it is
time for your job search it's not so
much making a jump it's kind of like
yeah I've prepared for this so yeah
that's a great way to kind of evaluate
your skills and see you know if I'm
applying for these jobs what are the
common things that I'm seeing so maybe
look at four or five job descriptions
and say okay all of them are asking for
me to have this experience and while I
learned it in my nano degree I don't
have the experience then you know what
experience you should be trying to find
or create for yourself let's see I
generally get positive feedback from
Udacity but I just got really negative
one from the same project from a company
so yeah that's a little bit different
this I would say you know potentially
reach out to the your group on student
hub or just on student hub in general
and see if anybody else can share some
ideas or feedback but I personally am
not kind of a technical expert so I
wouldn't necessarily know to too much
about that I think if it's in relation
to your application materials I would
encourage kind of going through some of
those webinars because those are a lot
more targeted and specific than some of
the on demand content even though that's
great it's just kind of a great start
and then also you have the option to
follow up with a career coach and kind
of go through that as well so I think it
depends on what your
you're asking but yeah they told
startups are not a safe option they
always go for downsizing what's your
opinion so I I know that you know it's
like anything else you know you could
have a very positive experience a lot of
people like startups because they
require them to you know wear multiple
hats so they may be doing one thing and
doing another thing and doing another
thing and enjoying that experience of
the variety whereas at a bigger company
you may be just doing this one thing and
that's all they want you to do they want
don't want you to take on additional
projects they don't want you to learn
about anything else they want you to do
that one job so sometimes startups can
be a little bit riskier obviously they
don't have as much financial founding as
a lot of major companies but it is it's
a case-by-case basis you know I would
say even if you have five friends who
have had horrible start-up experiences
that doesn't mean that your startup
experience is gonna be bad so you have
to like think critically about their
experiences of what they didn't like
learn from that if all of them were in
you know the media industry maybe lean
towards something else but reflect on
that and think critically about where
you could be different if you are still
considering startups it is a little bit
riskier but there are benefits as well
and they're they're willing to take
risks on people a lot more than some
bigger companies let's see um there was
a question I did my masters and looking
for a job for seven months right now I'm
learning predictive analytics and it has
no link to my master's degree which
strategy shall I go with so I think it
would help to know what your master's
degree was in but that could be a good
way for you to kind of bring them
together so maybe you do predictive
analytics in the industry where you got
your master's degree or where you have
some expertise or some experience so
that you can you know at least show that
like this is an intentional effort that
I learned this and I'm applying this at
the same time but I think ultimately
it's it's up to you and you know it
depends on your priorities are you
willing to wait out a longer job search
for something that you really really
want or do you need to get in a role
sooner and you have to be a little more
aggressive in that process and be open
to
different opportunities let's see does
Udacity offer prepping for an online job
interview yeah so I mean we are here to
kind of help you with everything as it
relates to the job search process so if
you want to and there may be there may
be a webinar on that as well I would
just double check you know
schedule some time to chat with the
coaching team take advantage of the
resources if I were you'd ask me student
I would use every single one of the
coaching sessions that I get I would
watch most of the webinars that relate
to me there's so so much value in those
that I have not seen elsewhere on the
Internet in general so really take
advantage of that if you do have access
to coaching calls we can help you with
your application materials we can help
you with your networking strategy we can
help you with your LinkedIn profile we
can help you write a cover letter we can
help you prepare for an interview we can
do a mock interview we can talk salary
negotiation you know we're here to help
you with all of the things you know as
much as we can but I will say just keep
in mind for the careers team we're not
the technical experts so you shouldn't
be scheduling a call with us to ask
about your upcoming technical interview
and what you should do to prepare for
that we're more so kind of on the
general side of things and and you know
keep in mind that we are not developers
on the career side let's take a couple
more questions I see there are three
more questions so I'll take these and
then we're gonna jump off and you guys
are gonna enjoy the rest of your day
so some recruiters asked to send the
application alongside with the predicted
salary what do you suggest and should it
be arranged so that's tough because some
situations they have you like put in a
thing and you can't include a range I
would say if you can always include a
range if not give them something
somewhere in the middle if you're trying
to figure out what that range is I would
suggest using something like
payscale.com or salary comm or even
LinkedIn
salary feature to search your the job
titles that you're you're interviewing
for as well as the location because your
location determines things
cost of living and that factors into
your salary so a lot of those websites
will actually give you a range to where
you have the low end and the high end
and the medium end and you have to kind
of critically think and evaluate where
do I fall based on my qualifications and
experiences and then you go with kind of
that range that you're creating as a
student looking for remote jobs on data
analytics what strategies should I use
so I think you can still use the same
strategy of finding companies that are
remote first there are a lot of
companies that were working fully
remotely even before kovat 19 who are
still looking specifically with people
with your expertise so you can still try
to connect with people at those
companies in advance if you have any
remote companies that are at the top of
your list
the other thing that I would say is
there is a webinar that I did on finding
remote jobs check that out but just keep
in mind think if I was gonna work
remotely what are the things I would
want to see on a resume that I would
want to hear in an interview so keep in
mind communication teamwork project
management all the things that make
working remotely difficult because those
are the things they're gonna be looking
for outside of just your expertise and
data analytics let's see yeah um so yeah
the playlists on YouTube so you can just
go to youtube search for Udacity go to
Udacity z-- page and then under the page
there's a tab for playlists if you click
on that playlist and you got a I think
kind of scroll over a little bit you'll
see the playlist for career webinars and
then there are 53 of those and so you
can just scroll through and I would just
say watch the ones that piqued your
interest most of them are around an hour
and the cool thing is it's YouTube so
you can pause and you can replay it and
you can do whatever I tell all of my
students if you're watching the LinkedIn
one go through that section pause it
change your profile go back rewatch
anything you might need to change it and
continue doing that as you make progress
but yeah um thank you all so so much for
attending today I appreciate the
engagement in the chat box as well so
thank you for showing up thank you for
the team that helped facilitate this I
appreciate you all staying engaged
throughout the entire presentation I
hope this was helpful I hope you start
implementing some of these things and
start
to see some progress but it outside of
that feel free to connect with me on
LinkedIn if you're interested in
connecting I have a lot of content on
there as well and we can just kind of
keep in contact there so yeah thank you
all so much for attending and have a
great rest of your day